hello everybody hope that you're good in
yesterday's video we were talking about
this liquidation Zone here between
twenty six thousand seven hundred and
twenty six thousand six hundred okay uh
it was quite a narrow Zone okay we could
mark it pretty well because we could see
that liquidity in hablo capital in the
seven days time frame liquidation hit
map so it was quite clear that you know
we were not finished dropping from here
um there was another drop coming and
then I posted on Twitter right at the
start of the Asian session that it's
likely you know that we see a test of
the 50ma and then a drop to this
liquidity Zone
so anybody that caught that perfect I'm
glad uh if you don't follow me on
Twitter we'll recommend you too because
I sometimes post updates there too and
now what I can see in the chat remember
that today is Thursday we've been
dropping price all the week and after we
stole you on Thursdays it's likely that
we see some kind of reversal okay so if
we've been dropping all the week the
reversal should be to the upside okay
that's what I'm anticipating for today
now is this drop organic in the way that
it didn't leave any balance behind let's
check okay let me remove this so the
chart is clear
um well okay in the one or time frame we
can see this liquidity pool over here
sorry let me Mark this better for you
I want settings like this and in general
so you can see better okay so you have
this liquidity pool this large red
candle here okay that it's been
partially filled at least I would say
it's been filled around maybe 55 percent
ish but if you notice here
this is a small liquidity pool so uh in
a way you have some kind of uh it's a
small in balanceable price could
basically come back here okay that's
what I mean and if we go to the 15
minutes time frame
you're gonna be able to see that it left
uh some sort of week behind okay it's
not much it's a hundred dollars a week
but uh you know that's also something
that you have to to note so why not
maybe we see if we continue seeing some
kind of uh rejection from here
okay we could still see something like
this you know as you've been dropping
and here it could be forming some kind
of double Reformation okay if it drops
from here you might expect this
liquidity pool here to get filtered in a
one hour time frame or the 50 of the
week in the 15 minutes time frame and
then bounce okay then from here if you
notice we're in the one hour time frame
um the 50ma in the one hour time frame
is at 27 161.
let me Mark it for you uh so you can
because I want to show you something
okay well
around there okay four dollars you're
gonna forgive me and in the four hour
time frame you notice that it's in the
same level it's at you guys in the top
left corner twenty seven thousand one
hundred seventy one so the difference is
only really uh ten dollars difference
between the 50 main the one hour time
frame and the 50 May in the four hour
time frame that is very interesting why
because that zone should be quite strong
resistance but if you flip the
resistance is going to become a very
strong support so if you see I mean
price unfavorable enough higher prices
by the way I mean long okay I will log
here so if price comes here all the way
here okay then we would expect some kind
of free test of the 50ma
and then continuation
okay
um I don't know if we'll play out in a
double view formation or just spoon from
here
um we'll see what happens but I'm
expecting something like this okay this
is what I'm expecting for today
um why this level 27 850. again I don't
know if you're gonna have enough time to
get there this week okay between two and
tomorrow but if you notice that zone
it's a very interesting Zone
because it's been tested multiple times
you had here testing it as support all
this time then here you have resistance
resistance
um again resistance and then price dumps
so you can see that that area it's a
very interesting so the price could go
back to all right uh that's what I'm
thinking let me remove this
um then sorry then eventually if we can
flip this Zone
okay from resistance into support then
we would expect you know latest of
support and then that's the 50 of the
week getting felt okay so those are the
my levels that I have marked to the
upside of course you know you have to be
careful because if we come again to the
one or 50ma
okay and price gets reacted strongly uh
then this double information is is not
possible for the simple fact that you
know you've come to the highs so you can
see that this doesn't really make much
sense okay uh these drops would be lower
so if it dumps and formidable
information should be from here really
uh if it comes here let me draw again if
it comes to the 50ma okay and it gets
reacted
then uh you have to keep an eye if you
see something like this okay if we don't
drop heavily and we are below the 50ma
you know testing interest resistance
then eventually we're gonna see a
push-up retest continuation
because that's basically what happened
here
okay that's what basically what happened
here you can see by the opposite side
you can see there is testing a support
but it's not really bouncing okay so
then what you could expect is drop below
it retest the resistance and continue
dropping okay or what happened here
okay you've come to the 50ma you don't
get above it really but you know you are
right below it for many hours then you
push price up retest continuation to the
upside okay so that's how you can
imagine press action to to be
of course
um
what I recommend you is to look for
Price action uh because in the way that
you know if you place a long order here
okay expecting a breakout then you have
to be very careful because you might see
a week and then price getting rejected
okay that's what I'm always telling you
the safest way to play here if you have
a long here okay is
these two options in my opinion that you
see a drop down okay and you can maybe
hope for other information
or if it keeps pumping here
then of course don't enter along below
resistance because if you enter along
before resistance it's basically the
same
price level that if you wait for a push
up
retrace and up here you can long okay
and you are long in support you are no
longer resistance so that's what I
recommend you if you are looking for
lungs but you are not yet into one all
right now what happens
if this is wrong and price is not going
up today okay what happens if price you
know maybe comes to the 1 or 50ma
get reacted this W pattern gets
invalidated and keeps dropping then we
have to look for the next one okay the
next one even to the four hour time
frame
squat clear I've marked yesterday I
think in the video and is this liquidity
pool that we have over here
okay
uh what quite close to it to be honest
a little bit that one
sorry let me Mark as well that one
between
twenty six thousand five hundred sixty
um twenty six thousand four hundred
seventy five okay and you also have this
one over here a bit lower too
okay
um that's all the way to twenty six
thousand two hundred forty
so that's pretty much what the chart is
telling me uh I think pretty much that
if we lose you know this Zone here
because you can see the let me remove
this you can see that this zone is quite
important in the chart
okay let me show you
let me remove the 50ma
you can see that this one is quite
important in the chart you know you had
here
support support
resistance support So if you lose this
Zone and we're talking about twenty six
thousand five hundred seventy okay so if
you look if you lose this then you are
eventually gonna go again
to probably below 20 well 26k
um if you lose this Zone you can go even
lower okay because again there is some
liquidity here well there is in fact a
bunch of liquidity here okay now we're
gonna go into high blood Capital we're
going to try to make sense of that chart
and see where the liquidity is okay see
if we can find any Confluence to favor
higher or lower prices wearing hablo
Capital we want to check those
Liquidations in the seven days time
frame I want to see that yellow bar
taking off the chart let's see there you
can see it guys uh 26
650 and 26 700 bar is gone off the chart
and you can see that now the liquidities
well there is a yellow that appeared in
a 28 100 okay that will be right above
this High here right and pretty close
also to the week the week is around only
50 percent of the week is around 20 250
so that one is pretty close to it all
right if it comes here
to 28 100 I'm not taking profits here
I'm gonna put into the 50 of the week
okay and to the downside you're going to
see some liquidity here uh right below
or key support level okay uh this is
around 26 250 so you have to be cautious
of that now if you go into the 12 hours
time frame let's see if we can see
something
in shorter term okay let's take this
Zone
okay this is very interesting because
he's telling us that the liquid is to
the upside
so this is giving Confluence to the idea
that today we might see higher prices
okay and you can see uh quite a lot of
liquidations at 27 225
um if I'm
not grown that's above the 50 Mas so who
knows if you see a spike up grab those
liquidations and then retrace to the
50ma maybe you can see price going
higher because you also have some
liquidations at 27 750 and again to the
downside
um not much okay I cannot really say
much while only focusing in the yellow
bars in the 12 hours time frame because
uh is usually quite a hectic time frame
and there is a lot of liquidity and in
the monthly time frame you can see that
they took those liquidations here okay
and I mean it's quite amazed okay I
cannot really take something from this
chart because uh in the monthly time
frame is very mixed now if we go into
the liquidation levels these also an
important chart because you can see the
Delta let's get there
okay so you can see that the lungs were
at risk okay there were a lot of long uh
liquidations at risk around seven
billion dollars at the top at 28 400 and
you can see that they hung them okay
price dropped these guys High leverage
Traders got liquidated and now if you
notice is the opposite okay because
there are eight and a half billion
dollars worth of short liquidations so
that means that the liquidity is to the
upset again if you check in that right
side of the chart you can see this
spikes
okay those are big amounts of
liquidations okay you can see that for
example this blue uh spikes means short
starting times 25 leverage okay and you
can see them for example at 28 275
around the week and also around 27
240 but then you can also see uh traders
that have gone times 100 leverage okay
that's that kind of gray here and that's
a 27 450.
so
is the market maker going to reverse
price
and liquidate those Traders
um I mean this is quite interesting so
to be honest because you have
you know the times 100 leverage Traders
at 27 470 and then you have traders that
are using times 50 leverage under
liquidations are at 27 750. so
I think it's quite likely that we see
higher prices game that's why I mean
along uh again I have my validation that
it you know losing that low that we have
a 26 600 if we lose that low then uh I
should cut my trade because we're
probably gonna go low okay but for the
meantime it's looking that they want to
go higher remember yesterday go and
checked this video
but we could also see a spike of
liquidity at 26 600 okay they took that
liquidity which we expected and then now
is what we could see a reversal because
that's the most efficient way okay they
found those High leverage traders that
were trying to run Longs quite early
okay so they couldn't them so now not
many people are into lungs okay so if
you check here above okay you can see
total short liquidations 419 total long
liquidations 800.
this is basically telling you that most
Traders are in shorts
okay
pair one Trader going long you have
almost three Traders going short
okay so that is interesting the
liquidity is to the upside and this can
give us an idea that if we see a
reversal okay then these are your
targets okay 27 500 27 760.
and of course
this big boy here twenty eight thousand
three hundred and that's also the 50 of
the week okay so those are the three
targets that you could for example use
for taking profits okay back in the
charts I mean the dollar index chart
because today should be a big day for
the charts okay should be quite a
volatile leak so don't go into high
leverage trades because today is not the
day okay the debt ceiling got approved
officially I've been telling you all
this time that yes they were going to
get approved don't worry they've been
doing this 78 times now is the 79th
times since 1960 so it was clear that
they were just uh doing some kind of a
show okay
so I explained it in 2001 to go much
into detail but basically we had some
sort of uh agreement but it wasn't
approved now it got officially approved
so let's see how the market react to it
today okay now in the dollar Index you
know it's playing out this beautiful W
formation that we anticipated a lot if
you're going to the four hour time
frames you can see that it's dropping
let me see there just loaded uh it's
dropping and it seemed that it might be
dropping towards the 50ma okay the 50ma
is right now at
103.50 okay so let me Mark it for you
guys
is this one here okay 103.50
or the five now if we wanted the one
hour time frame okay
you're gonna notice that this one it's a
very important soul in the chart okay
because if we take it from here
all right you can see that it's a quite
a strong support I'll probably say the
the like I would probably say that if
you drop below this Zone here
because you can see that there is for
example a liquidity pool here a smaller
one here uh that will be a big drop okay
as you can see that will take you to
100 3.1 and then remember that if the
federal index goes down Bitcoin can go
up right so pay attention to it it's a
little now uh
very long week behind so who knows maybe
it traces this week then maybe Bitcoin
can drop and you know who knows maybe
formatable information in the lower time
frame and then the dollar can continue
dropping if it loses this Zone then it's
gonna go lower and that's when between
could go again to 28k okay so a bit of
Confluence that in the chart
in the one hour time frame but not in
the four hour time frames and in the
photo time frame the 50 image also this
strong support so let's see if we can
test the support and bounce or if it
falls below it and continue going lower
okay that's basically what I'm looking
at in the dollar Index
so that's pretty much everything guys a
quick recap is that the important level
in Bitcoin at the moment is the 50ma in
the one hour and in the four hours time
frame because it's you know at the same
level only 10 dollars different so if
you see you know a push-up and a retrace
and tested a support then here you know
you can be very confident the price is
gonna continue going high okay maybe
even fill this liquidity pool also if we
check the Liquidations in high block you
can see that the liquidity now is to the
upside okay they just fill this one here
between twenty six thousand seven
hundred and twenty six thousand six
hundred thousand is now heat is clear
and the liquidity now is to the upside
where well round numbers really 27 250
27 500 27
28k and twenty eight thousand two
hundred fifty you know every two hundred
fifty quite round numbers pretty much so
today's bias is going to be uh to the
upside I'm favoring again higher prices
uh I mean alone from this sum very happy
about it to be honest and let's see what
it does again there's a chance of a w
formation here okay uh or if not you can
just expect a push and hopefully to not
get a strong reaction at the 50ma
because again if you lose this low here
okay sorry let me remove this if you
lose this load here
that one there
if you lose 26 550 then price is gonna
drop another at least 500 okay that's
where there is support okay so that's
pretty much everything guys hopefully
this plays out
um again be very careful today could be
quite a volatile day hopefully it
benefits and it goes up let's see what
happens and thank you so much for
watching guys and I'll see you soon